bom dia é falar um pouco contar a nossa
história da cooperativa arte peixe
a cooperativa de peixe lá em são joão da
barra em atafona e mostrando ainda a
primeira foto é o mercado de peixe que
ele não estava sendo utilizado né
estava até virando um ponto de droga e
aí em 2007
a gente recebeu um curso do projeto
produzir ea partir desse curso
a gente começou a desenvolver a nossa
cooperativa
aqui é a nossa primeira presidente dona
jacira que é a minha mãe e que me
ensinou muito
o que é ter garra o que é lutar pelos
sonhos não é a minha mãe já mesmo com
toda dificuldade ela sempre acreditou
ela sempre lutou e sempre acreditou que
a gente poderia fazer a cooperativa arte
peixe alcançar um mundo né é assim que a
gente quer
aqui a gente já tá no outro é ponto né e
hoje depois de passar nesses longos dez
anos a gente teve ajuda de vários
parceiros que desenvolveu essa logo para
a gente lá na cooperativa a gente faz o
processamento de pescados são mulheres
de pescadores ou com histórico pesqueiro
que formaram em 2007 a partir de um
curso de qualificação a cooperativa arte
peixe voltada para o beneficiamento do
pescado e elaboração de produtos
inovadores para o mercado
e aí então as mulheres da cooperativa
arte peixe néon umas guerreiras porque
não é fácil né não aqui ninguém tem
curso ninguém fez faculdade enfim
mulheres de pescadores que hoje são
empreendedoras
a gente faz a nossa cooperativa produtos
naturais e artesanais
então aqui a gente faz o hamburg de
camará um hambúrguer de camarão ele é
100% natural
não tenho glúten aqui está o hambúrguer
de peixe
o quibe de peixe conseguindo passar aqui
sim
e aqui a gente tem um croquete de
camarão a cooperativa de peixe nesse
longo desses 10 anos né não não foi
fácil para a gente chegar até aqui nesse
momento
então a gente contou com várias
parcerias e mostrei lá no começo o
mercado de peixe ele estava desativado
então a gente contou com a prefeitura de
são joão da barra para fazer a obra as
adequações que são necessários nem pra
gente trabalhar com alimento e aí o
projeto produzir que eu falei lá no
começo teve o seu mar também é um md a
gente sempre participou de feiras do mda
na marina da glória em salvador brasília
a cooperativa de pechão já ficou entre
as cinco melhores do brasil então hoje a
gente serve de exemplo para outras
cooperativas
a gente tem uma câmera fria que foi a
doação da shell a universidade cândido
mendes sempre apoiou a gente na questão
de contabilidade de administração sempre
teve apoiando afi perde sempre
acompanhou a cooperativa desde o início
desde que foi fundado em 2007 efe perde
acompanha arte peixe
a faperj também foi um edital que
ganhamos e compramos equipamentos têm as
off tem o ferro porte que hoje está bem
ligada à arte peixe também foi o porte
de prumo né que está com
porto do açu está apoiando bastante o
instituto consulado da mulher
a gente foi premiado também fomos lá em
são paulo
e aconteceu coisas muito interessantes
lá também o reconhecimento que são todas
as mulheres que estavam lá sendo
reconhecidas pelo trabalho que faz
a enac vito são alunos lado cefet
maracanã que foi o que desenvolveu para
a gente essa nova logomarca que vem
acompanhando não é só os jovens e
acredito muito no trabalho que a gente
faz tem o pescar ti também é um parceiro
da arte peixe que está também agora
desenvolvendo tanques de pescados até
mesmo pra que esses peixes possa ser
utilizado na cooperativa
então na verdade no futuro a gente quer
fazer que é uma rede
a gente não quer ficar só em são joão da
barra
a gente quer também contribui com outras
mulheres com outras pessoas passando a
nossa nossa experiência que a gente tem
para que as pessoas possam crescer
também nesse ramo
como eu disse a cooperativa arte peixe
ela fica em são joão da barra
eu quero agradecer muito a vocês e dizer
o que a gente faz lá é o amor é o amor
ao ofício é o amor do que a gente gosta
o que a gente acredita
são mulheres que mesmo no mês não
consiga levar o dinheiro para a sua casa
nesses longos dez anos existe fundadoras
que estão lá até hoje
meu muito obrigado a vocês
[Aplausos]